I was the best what I did a hacker a  thief I got in got out no one got hurt  until I discovered something I was never  meant to see that's when they came for  me but kill her now I'm coming for them  someone ordered a hit on me whatever's  in those files will lead me to them you  want revenge this phone can turn the  city into a weapon  your men are expendable mr. Iraq my  Empire is not John forget who runs this  city trillions of box of information at  your fingertips  want to tell me what's going on  corporate espionage crooked cops  big explosion funny  tired stories man that like nothing you  ever seen before  okay we got a bunch of dead bodies right  we got 40,000 people above us we need a  distraction  I want to name in that server  Oh  so you're the [ __ ] raining down on me  you're interfering with my plans you  took something valuable from me  where are they  mr. Shute you gotta walk away from this  man some things you can't walk away from